[Musique]
voilà donc but de ce dernier quart de
finale de cette première journée journée
du grand prix des chefs de bordeaux donc
on a vu déjà trois quarts de finale
s'est terminée aujourd'hui donc je
rappelle les résultats à ceux qui
viendraient maintenant donc alberto
david a battu yoann benita ensuite c'est
laurent frayssinet qui s'est qualifié
pour les demi finales lui aussi en
battant le champion d'aquitaine 2006
donc marc lui est ce que franck hargot
s'est désisté champion d'aquitaine 2007
et donc dans le match convient de suivre
à 20 heures et bien c'est hicham
hamdouchi qui s'est fait éliminer par
romain edouard donc romain edouard qui
rejoint aussi les demi finales donc il
rencontrera - d'alors alberto david
demain à 17 heures donc un match sans
doute passionnant entre romain edouard
et alberto david du nord qui réussit
peut-être la perf de la journée
il reste un grand match ce soir et reste
un grand match puisque le vainqueur de
ce match déjà rejoindre les demi finales
c'est sûr et jouera aussi contre laurent
frayssinet un des grands favoris de ce
tournoi qui pour l'instant lui n'est pas
éliminé il est toujours là et bien ce
grand match va opposer deux joueurs
vraiment très très intéressant à plus
d'un titre alors le premier d'entre eux
on a tenu à l'invité cette année au
grand prix l'échec de bordeaux parce que
c'est le premier maître international
bordelais oui il est il est tout jeune
et champion de france juniors
il est donc maître international donc en
route pour devenir grand maître il a dû
quitter bordeaux d'ailleurs pour
continuer sa progression il maintenant à
cannes il a été formé ici à bordeaux et
donc je vous demande d'accueillir bien
le local de l'épreuve veut rentrer signé
lui aussi étendre la région mais pas de
bordeaux donc ici de bordeaux le maître
international mathieu cornette mathieu
cornette
bonjour mathieu alors content de jouer
ici à bordeaux sur des terres en fête
comment ça se passe notamment grâce à
donc à tous les moyens qui sont mis en
oeuvre je vais le rappeler ici
donc vous avez des casques pour écouter
les commentaires vous avez donc cet
écran géant sur lequel on va suivre la
partie en direct connectés l'échiquier
on pourra illustré avec avec des flèches
aussi donc c'est match ce match en deux
parties de 20 minutes par joueur est
suivi donc des pistes de départage comme
on vient de le voir ici un match qui
s'est terminé au couteau était un peu
débordé d'ailleurs voilà donc le premier
participant aussi le maître
international mathieu cornette alors
face à lui un des grands grands joueurs
français c'est un des premiers grands
maîtres internationaux en france il ya
trente ans en france il y avait aussi un
grand maître international
aujourd'hui on a à peu près une
vingtaine c'est un des pionniers il a
été membre de l'équipe d'anatolie carpet
au championnat du monde en 1990 c'est
dire comme il intéressé comme il a
toujours intéressé les plus grands
joueurs du monde comme il a pu jouer au
meilleur joue au niveau mondial et
continuer à le faire
il est plus un peu plus passé
aujourd'hui au niveau du côté des
entraîneurs il est entraîneur national
des équipes de france notamment équipe
france jeunes et c'est notamment
l'entraîneur de romain edouard qu'on a
vu battre tout à l'heure aux riches en
bauchi donc il est très connu en france
très aimé je vous demande d'applaudir et
d'encourager le grand maître
international olivier remis au goût du
jour l'idée donc je crois alors tu es né
à bordeaux à cenon à cenon voilà bien ce
dont je suis fier d'avoir été invité à
ce tournoi est très prestigieux voilà
merci il va écouter sans plus tarder on
va faire appel à notre arbitre
international patrick besse vous avant
de l'accueillir aussi patrick besse
cette odyssée leur merci
et bien pas trop que je te laisse les
rênes pour organiser enfin pour arbitrer
ce grand mas internationales bâle merci
merci stéphane nous allons procéder au
tirage au sort des couleurs conte savoir
commencera avec les blancs ce match
henry minutes et 6 lits à vis de
départage nous jouerons le blitz avec
les couleurs opposées c'est à dire que
celui qui aura commencé avec les blancs
commencera avec les noirs et enfin on
retirera au sort s'il y a à nouveau un
beat mort subite
voilà donc on y est
si vous entendez lever la main ouais
c'est bon donc c'est tout marche bien
donc alors oui il faut attendre un peu
un coup de maître cornette qui a
remporté le toss
il débutera donc le match avec les noirs
donc c'est olivier rhône et qui va avoir
les blancs les blancs en faut pas tenir
compte des coûts qui seront là en fait
ça va pas jouer alors par contre j'ai un
soucis avec la pendule juste je demande
à voilà c'est parti voiture sera celle
ci suit donc d4 début du puits en dames
cavaliers m6 c4 et la e6 cornette neige
ou palestiniennes alors nous sommes ici
mais aux commandes
stéphane laborde avec renault laguna
l'une président de l'échiquier bordelais
ici dont les premiers coups joués pour
cette partie dont on est à peine remis
quand gilles sur à oui oui c'était un
match très chaud très disputée avec
finish superbe gagné par le jeune le
jeune romain edouard joueurs talentueux
donc ici la défense nemirovitch et la
variante c'est ça j'en ai des 5 des
sommes jouées par mathieu cornette a
laissé 3 voilà donc c'est un début du
conte dame donc c'est un candidat ment
fait en cabine à m'accepter là il vient
de prendre
mathieu cornette voilà donc prend le
centre ici sont la case si central ici
on a poussé le pion c4 pour s'échanger
contre le pion central et on va sans
doute reprendre du fou voilà
tranquillement alors c'est un peu comme
comme au foot
renault quand on est blanc en premier il
faut surtout ne pas perdre il faut oui
essayé de tenir la position et de faire
valoir ses fameux avantages du très qui
est le fait de commencer la partie et
donc d'imposer quelque part sa loi avec
7 à cette avance de donne tant qu'on
essaie de garder le plus longtemps
possible prendre l'initiative jouer et
le joueur des noirs lui il est censé
essayer d'égaliser et de créer le plus
vite possible des problèmes aux blancs
pour pouvoir animer la partie donc
issifou b4 c'est un des thèmes de l'idée
au cices c'est de placer le flou en
jambes et 4 il attaque le cavalier
surtout l'idée c'est de contrôler la
case ou 4 évidemment avec le fouet
cavaliers on empêche les blancs de jouer
ou quatre qui est l'idée aussi du coup
dans le dos on protège la poussée on a
vu ça déjà dans un premier temps
tout à l'heure donc le cavaly le fou ici
peut s'échanger à tout le monde contre
calais qui contrôle la case de 4 oui
mais il va y va attendre pour pour
s'échanger à palau n'est tout de suite
tout de suite le fou contre le cavalier
donc là il organise ces pièces à hay est
proprement les deux joueurs en début
soigné petit rock opposés aux petits
rockeurs les noirs vont essayer
d'attaquer le centre blanc et les blancs
vont essayer de le maintenir le plus
possible donc tour theory centralisée
tour sur les colonnes tout ça est tout à
fait normal et académique alors tours 8
mathieu lui est un fin tacticien bon
calculateur qui est imaginatif créatif
moi je le connais bien puisque
je l'avais entraîner bien sûr quelques
années voilà un preneur voilà c'était
aussi une satisfaction pour toi de le
voir maintenant tout à fait laisser au
niveau là bien sûr c'est ce qui me
conforte dans mon idée de continuer à
développer les échecs sur le plan
bordelais ce que j'avais fait en créant
le club de la rue but en 92 donc ça fait
quinze ans que j'essaie de former des
jeunes et la meilleure récompense à tout
ce temps tous ces investissements c'est
un mathieu corne est un jeune formé au
club et puis découvert dans les écoles
dans une école de bordeaux et un talent
naturel
déjà tout petit il était très vif quand
on faisait les entraînements oui
combatif aussi combatif
très combatif et puis il a battu laurent
frayssinous oui mais sans préciser s'il
avait tonné oui je connais ses qualités
je connais toutes ses qualités
un tournant à paris et ils nous avaient
fait la joie d'être d'être champion de
france minime puis championne france
cadets puis champion de france junior
c'est à dire les trois catégories
majeures des jeunes ce qui n'avait
jamais été fait par aucun jeune d'aucun
club de france même parmi les ceux qui
sont devenus grands maîtres ce qui peut
que nous encourager à penser qui va
devenir très vite grand mère il a déjà
fait une norme
il lui reste deux normes de grands
maîtres à faire pour avoir le titre oui
là 2011 comme il est très jeune ça va il
est de 1400 et quelques uns
pas l'om de 2005 oui bien sûr donc il
est à peu près du niveau puisqu'il faut
deux mille cinq cents lots pour
patrouiller quand m oui oui et puis bon
il a choisi un bon pour l'instant
en club on va revenir un peu à la partie
ça s'est un peu avancé donc on a vu
toujours pareil comme on avait vu un peu
cet après midi donc le petit roquet a
été fait le roi donc et bien à l'abri
derrière ses pions donc le noir a bien
réagi en jouant ses cinq pour attaquer
ce centre blanc qui ont eu six et cinq
ont attaqué le centre ici on reprend
d'une tour voilà pour équilibrer les
aides pour équilibrer les forces au
centre mais ça y était lié donc l'idée
c'est pour les blancs c'est d'avoir ici
des deux colonnes ce qu'on appelle
l'école ouverte parce qu'il ya plus de
pions sur ces colonnes donc on peut
voyez que les tours sont libres de
pouvoir attaquer suffit side d'enlever
ces pièces que la source puis se bouger
on mesure ce qu'on peut pas l'enlever et
comment faire que la peinture est sur
une colonne loupé ce plan là pareil on
ne peut pas l'enlever on peut pas
décider de le mettre là on n'a pas le
droit
il peut aller que tout droit donc
l'avantagé quand il pleut on peut
toujours enlever les pièces elles
peuvent s'enlever est donc libéré les
colonnes voilà donc là d'une lutte pour
l'activation des pièces pour les
colonnes le dernier coup ici de maître
cornette qu'elle laissait scène propose
un échange de tours on voit l'intérêt
que les tours sont liés là aussi le
petit roquet a été fait le roi bien à
l'abri derrière les pions et en cas d'
échanges sur cette tour ici et bien la
tour à 8 peut revenir en des 8 et donc
on remplace une tour par une autre d'où
l'intérêt de lier les tours oui et de
pouvoir coulisses et de ne pas concéder
une colonne à l'adversaire donc il
essaie de contester la colonne donc je
tourne autour des 8 pour soulager la
pression des tours sortent sur la
colonne des alors on peut dire sur ce
match comme olivier rhône est peut-être
légèrement favori mais
oui parce qu'il est grand maître qu'il
est grand mais d'expérience c'est qu'il
a mais mathieu à la jeunesse avec lui
donc voilà donc ça peut très bien être
un atout aussi je pense que mathieu aura
plus de chance dans les parties rapides
que que dans l'est je parle des médecins
dans l'église st sissili aller vite
plus que dans les partis parti à de 20
minutes ou olivier et rené va sans doute
faire jouer le coin s'est laissé
déborder facilement d'un ac ou d'olivier
rhône et b3 pourquoi pas donc ça protège
à 4 donc parce que les menaces et de
foot français 3 et cavaliers prend à 4
c'était une c'était une des menaces
petit gagné un pion bon il a défendu
discutable mais ce qu'il faut voir si ça
près avec la tour qui attaquent le
cavalier enfin c'est compliqué il peut y
avoir des échanges de tours vont pas
rentrer là dedans mais voilà donc petit
coupé 3 je protège le pion à 4 qui est
quand même sous la menace du cavalier je
soutiens aussi le pouce et 4 oui leur
nom oui oui on se fout c4 est pas très
heureux là sur cette case accroché à son
client accroché au plan b 3 les pièces
les pièces noires sans quelque peu plus
libre tours s'est vite donc tour ses
huit craindre pour son retour il
prendrait de la tour oui oui oui il faut
la tour mais c'est pas grave puisque il
y aurait récupération de la colonne des
dons qu'il faudrait sans doute que le
glas joue aussi tour des impôts pour
s'opposer à la colonne des dons classé
doit prendre tour ce qui est fait on
prend sûrement reprendre alors il peut
prendre le ton ou envisagé de l'entamer
non non il va prendre la toîle avait
pris de la dame
probablement les blancs ont joué le tour
des uns et la dame ordures jouer donc là
en prenant de la tour sur tournée on
peut envisager d'échanger échanger les
tours donc voilà les noirs ans
totalement égaliser cette position
équilibrée qui s'en sort bien wissam ans
connaît bien son sujet c'est un c'est un
gars qui prépare bien ses débuts quand
il des 4 il travaille beaucoup pour un
pour essayer d'obtenir ces deux normes
qui lui manque
ou alors le problème des normes aussi
aujourd'hui c'est de trouver des
tournants fermé voilà donc c'est la
fédération qui qui propose au jeune
espoir français des des tournois à
l'étranger quand ils obtiennent des
invitations ou en français quand il est
au tournoi organisé dans certaines
villes donc ici cavaliers des quatre
voilà donc ce cavalier obtient une belle
case à une belle case si on veut si on
veut déloger ce cavalier la case des
quatre il faut jouer le pion 1,5 mais ça
veut dire est dir est évidemment la
diagonale ça donnerait de l'air asu et
qui t'a pris sur le pouce est donc ce
cavalier est bien installé en décapitant
plus que très bien installèrent black
hat à l'heure c'est le fameux cavaliers
kasparov way qui voit un pion oui
paraît-il oui selon kasparov oui le
cavalier seul 5e bien installé oui donc
bon c'est parce qu'on travaille ici et
il ne serait pas prenable par le pion
eux puisque s'il serait pas d'un plan le
curieux ici oui mais sur ce problème
ce coût 5 semble pas du tout une option
donc son cavalier du coup est très fort
parce que donc du coup il est protégé
par le pion aux trois et ils bouchent
l'action de cette tour des huit alors
très souvent les les joueurs
d'expérience se contente d'améliorer
constamment leurs pièces six ans le
souci d'avoir des pièces bien placé
parce qu'ici c'est oui bien placés sur
des bonnes cases et active parce qu'ils
savent que tôt ou tard servir à la pièce
active est bien placé va
tôt ou tard ça serve pas faire quelque
chose c'est utile à participer à une
combinaison
alors attention 17 c'est intéressant il
l'idée ça pour être joué deux cavaliers
au sein attaquée ce pont ou une autre
idée peut être de jouer cavalier c4
peut-être et pour éliminer le cavalier
noir et puis pour un essayé d'envahir
c'était casse de quatre autres cavaliers
pouvant faire le relais sur ces cinq et
quatre ans ils ont une autre idée
j'étais en train de calculer sur
cavaliers le 5 le fou a pas de kazeon
mena sans plus car il y prend fou oui
n'ont pas calé pour tout d'abord fou
prend cavaliers 6 3 par exemple vous
prend ensuite car il prend fouet sur
d'am-dam prend fou des cinq gagne depuis
maintenant en tout cas semble gagné bon
faut calculer peut-être précisément
enfin voila c'est compliqué à
l'imposition là il commence à y avoir
des choses il n'y a pas beaucoup de
pièces échangées ya eu que deux pions
d'échanger les pions c et d ces deux sur
ses 2 colonnes là on voit bien qu'il ya
eu fusion du côté blanc ni du côté noir
ils ont été échangés voilà cavaliers ces
deux libéraux n'est décidé le fleuve le
foot doit s'échanger alors ça s'appelle
poser la question le foot doit s'est
chargé puisque s il se retira à cinq il
ya une fourchette par les trois des
quatre b 4 a qu'à la fois le fou à 5 et
le cas au lycée saint guen une pièce
tout simplement
donc il faut sans doute prendre
ou alors si une entre notre coût
possible c'est de jouer la scène
oui mais jouer à saint caprais cavaliers
prendrions prend les pions seront
doublés on n'était pas très bon on aura
concédé la paire de fou on aura des
pieds en double et qui seront une
faiblesse non je pense que l'on cammas
cavaliers à l'air force et sauf si un
coup tactique nous échappe au franc fou
prend donc seuil et olivier a créé le
premier déséquilibre la position il a
réussi à obtenir les deux fous ils
attaquent le fossé 3 mais effectivement
quand tu vois une haute et les blancs
dans la paire de fous rires là on la
perd de fruits une foule qui braquent un
fou très puissant et le trou les cases
d'horreur très puissante
j'ai une passion mais c'est pas possible
parce que attention il pourrait y avoir
des menaces toute pénétration
oui oui sans doute pas évident de savoir
mettre ce fou il veut sans doute le
garder olivier ronnie oui il va
peut-être jouer faux b2g pas ses
poursuivants et bellegarde y fait aussi
envisagée 4 je pense qu'il va garder le
fou ce faux valère le fou et attaquer
tout de suite voilà donc il a joué il a
pas gardé la cavalière septembre et non
de prendre sans doute il va prendre
mathieu cornette ici je suis étonné
qu'il n'ait pas gardé le faut oui parce
que c'est un puissant quand même un qui
voyagent 4 noir taper sur g7
oui même si c'est la seule pièce qui
pour l'instant active active contre le
roi mais c'est vrai que c'était un fou
qui avait l'air puissant cavaillon ben
brik et surtout qui n'avaient pas
d'opposant puisque vous c'est rarement
la sphère les renvois l'aï réparée
rétabli l'équilibré des forces
la femme est ce qu'à ses saints que de
passage pour les cavaliers et le fou
doublé de klaas blanche des noirs est
plus puissant que celui de lui si tu
veux dire oui ses fruits sans suite à
une grande
il ya une grande diagonale il est actif
or le double intérêt du cook avait
laissé cinq c'était un que sa protégée à
six parce qu'il faut pas oublier
maintenant que la batterie dame foot ap
/ à 6 1 je croyais voilà donc tout cas
les protège à 6 avec l'aide du fonds
bessette et aussi ce cavalier menaces et
peut-être devenir en quatre attaquants
la tour c'est pour ça qu'on y est on est
vous pensez de tout de suite oui veut
pas qu'il a envie de jouer b4 un jour ou
l'autre pour chasser ce cavalier et il
veut pas que les cavaliers prend 1,4
avec tempo sera pour ces trois d'or
qu'il a sorti sa tour a même atteint 7 e
tour était en l'air devant qu'il fallait
toujours avoir un oeil dessus c'est
laura il a fait des redites la petite
fenêtre
la petite fenêtre qui évite le fameux
match du couloir le roi pourra venir se
cacher sur cette case en cas d'échec sur
la première rangée plus tard dans la
partie
donc c'est un coup prophylactique on a
pu le dire cet après midi oui et puis
comment ça qu'on y est commencent à
mettre les épis rang sur sur case noire
donc si j'ai cette es6 surclasse noir ou
un profil tactique t2 voilà ça y est
donc c'est un peu ce que je proposais
il faut pas laisser la tour puissante
sur la sur la colonne et un peu
tranquille donc c'était l'idée de tours
tour ces deux c'était de pouvoir reposer
la tour sur la colonnade et pour pas que
les noirs et les mains libres sur cette
colonne donc échanges dame prend un
accord il veut changer
on s'achemine vers une nulle tranquille
voilà et puis empirant comprendre
qu'elle allait prendre les trois points
en b3 mathieu cours net et ça va être
nul parce que là il ya quand même des
loyers mais il faudra donc non violente
donc ça risque de trouver là ça y est
c'est fait voilà donc une nulle
finalement assez tranquille qui fait les
affaires de nature à dieu je pense qu'il
atteint sonneurs pour le jura ou didelon
très équilibré et jouer les parties et
le véhicule
voilà deux positions tranquille voilà
l'idée c'est que après que les noirs et
prix en bessin gones auraient repris ici
comme des joueurs d'après risque dernier
pion aurait sauté ici voilà donc une
première partie tranquille qui s'est
terminé vite
aucun joueur n'a pris de risque qu'ils
en quelques minutes de pause alors à
signaler que
[Musique]